herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich bin ein bisschen in eile deshalb
habe ich mich kurz ist sicherlich diesem
video von irgendwelchen eismänner die
irgendwelche heftigen tricks machen
durch die reichen die die wackelnden das
momentum
und davon habe ich ein ganzes video
gefunden und das möchte ich heute zu
sagen euch anschauen losgehen wie ein
holzfäller anfeinden allererste what the
heck wie geht dahin wo er wird nicht
müde jetzt wieder beim kommando the hurt
locker erfassen weltrekord wo verein das
ding ist ich weiß nicht vielleicht hab
ich mal weg probiert holz so
unwahrscheinlich schwierig weil sie
beachten damit die erste mit richtig
viel kraft schwingen wird auch die
studie liefert er macht aber sowohl vom
bund
martens dinger hintereinander was da los
die haben wir junge frau davon hängt das
weitere straßen verkaufsstände und das
ist wie macht irgendwie so kleine
teilchen und bringt die einfach genau
einfach nur mit dem auge den sieben
förmchen rein was macht er aber erneut
und wechselte die probleme von drei
sekunden geht es auch fangen
es ist gar nicht so ohne ich hab jetzt
auch schon fotoshooting gehabt mit kann
ich sagen das sieht immer leicht aus so
modellen sollte ich meine kritiker morde
freue mich auf ein paar fotos gemacht
worden
es ist ein komischer moment so mit einem
fotografen und sowas und dann so kraft
braucht sein wird echt nicht schlecht
alter schwede was bin ich wer ich mich
zwiebelschneiden dauert 30 minuten
gefühl irgendwie wir essen weiter gesagt
am anfang habe ich da bock drauf als ich
glaube nicht dass essen sowie torwart
wäre schon okay zugegebenermaßen ist
schon schnell
aber gibt es nicht so krank wie der
holzfäller zum beispiel also sehr gut
doch das einfach nicht unmenschlich okay
was macht er schneiden gemüse helfen
auf einer kleinen bank wo ich koche dann
wärmer wird aber ich fühle mich wie der
letzte versager wenn sie videos anschaut
kann man beweisen machen ob wir was
macht werden
ach ich das gut verpackt butter 1
also ich weiß nicht genau was los ist
aber ich weiß dass er unheimlich kraft
da drin ist dass zu vereinfachen ich
meine menschen sind schnell ohne fragen
die hier in dieser compilation bin aber
wir sind halt trotzdem nicht so schnell
die maschinen kein mensch kann so
schnell wie mit maschine so ein ding
einpacken
also wie ich finde auch ihre dass er
diesen job hat das eingesetzt wurde
als nächstes kommt ihr müsst ihr wissen
natürlich fragt warum machst du das
video überhaupt über schnelle menschen
ich kriege so oft gesagt dass ich
aussehe wie grant gattin also der
schauspieler von flash in der serie
ich war übrigens auch an karneval als
verkleidet
und dann meine was passt besser zu mir
als schneller arbeiter endlich arbeit
ich gar nicht weiter verfolgt wird wer
macht was er für den schlaf zu spielen
die vespa natürlich genau was er macht
ja irgendwie mauer war mein gott einen
mann muss ich leider feststellen dass es
fähig ist wenn ich mich rasiere gutes
bisher in bavendorf aber wenn die
passagiere wie endet das meistens
irgendwie so und ich brauche so lange
dafür und er achtet einfach so aus weil
irgendwann richtig lange war das geht ab
wie rasch das habe ich eine post dorthin
komplett eskaliert aufgegeben ich mich
schlecht das richtig ich habe überhaupt
keine ahnung wie lange man braucht man
so sachen so kraft drauf hat was macht
ihr das bewegt mich wie schafft er
überhaupt
also läuft jetzt auch ein wenig von den
letzten vier wo er dass es kraft
so ihre bücher vorstellen dieser zeit
als sänger 34 wechsel bekommen alles
möglich ist also das ist echt krass
ich hoffe mal das video hat euch
gefallen auch wenn das nur so einrichten
ding war
ich würde gerne wieder öfters
beziehungsweise täglich wenn nicht
irgendwie auf die reihe kriege videos
machen und da ist es halt schwierig
immer so eigene ideen zu haben so zum
beispiel zu spielen die ich mir überlegt
zu ablöschen auch mini challenge und das
sind ja alles ideen die von mir kommen
und so was jeden fall zu bringen scheint
ein bisschen schwierig deshalb hab ich
hab euch gefallen ich persönlich mag
sowas auch echt gerne und wir sehen uns
einmal nicht mal wieder bis dahin und